ce weekend a lieu le 26e ralliqueur de
France du côté de Vendôme et oui l'heure
est au dernier préparatif pour les
quelques 106 équipages qui vont
s'engager ce week-end sur les routes de
Loir-et-Cher les meilleurs pilotes
français partiront au volant d'Alpine de
Porsche ou encore de C3 de quoi ravir le
public pour cette étape du Championnat
de France des Rallyes zoom sur ce grand
spectacle à venir avec Romain Delville
pour la septième inscription du Rallye
cœur de France au championnat de France
Johan bonatto vise le Grand Chelem lui
qui a gagné les six éditions précédentes
le haut savoyard est en tête au
classement général après 6 épreuves il
compte bien creuser l'écart on
Loir-et-Cher ça nous correspond bien il
y a pas beaucoup de dénivelé c'est assez
plat par rapport à chez moi on a
beaucoup moins de montagnes c'est des
petites bosses on va dire mais
c'est pas pour autant que il y a pas des
petites descentes qui font que la
voiture prend de la vitesse donc voilà
c'est un rallye c'est un rallye qu'on
aime bien qu'on affectionne
particulièrement parmi les locaux de
l'étape dans la famille rocher je
demande le grand-père Jean-Luc venu pour
le plaisir du pilotage sur ces terres et
présent sur le cœur de France depuis le
tout début du cœur de France j'ai connu
encore mieux parce que j'y suis né donc
il y a une spéciale qui ont le droit le
départ là où je suis né donc je les
connais par cœur mais vous savez que
notre Parker une route parce qu'on y est
passé à vélo en culotte courte et puis
passer en course c'est de choses
différentes on l'avantage qu'on a ici
toute la famille c'est que on a moi j'ai
fait des
26ème cœur de France donc je commence à
les connaître pas mal tandis que Pierre
son fils vise le titre dans la catégorie
alpine Arthur le petit fils est inscrit
dans le trophée Clio à 19 ans l'étudiant
a marketing continue son apprentissage
sur la sphère
au moins une quinzaine de fois quand
j'étais petit je le venais le voir
chaque année c'était c'était obligatoire
c'était le rallier à la domicile donc
ouais non on connaît bien les spéciales
on aime bien venir ici c'est c'est un
plaisir d'être là et puis cette année il
y a le trophée donc moi je trouve ça
super en TP ultime étape du championnat
de France le rallye Loiret syrien a
l'habitude de célébrer le futur champion
réponse dimanche après-midi sur les
coups de 14 heures
[Musique]